dad nothing in my life is working out
for me
i just want to be like you i want to be
a cop makes me happy to hear you say
that son
get a drink come on let's get a drink i
i can't i'm driving home
oh you're a [ __ ] cop now come on
you're a cop
you want to be a cop well let me tell
you what being a cop is all about
it's about fear some of the [ __ ] i've
been through
there used to be a crackhead with cystic
fibrosis he was a real smart ass you
know these guys with cystic fibrosis to
roll like this
you see him like this one day i walked
over to him
and he was she was sassing me and i put
my [ __ ] gun right in his mouth
and he begged me to kill him he said
kill me he said kill me
kill me and i didn't [ __ ] kill him i
wanted to
but i didn't he was begging me to do it
overall i'm a peaceful man what is
most important is that my son knows who
i am
i'm the same man that came home and
bloodied you good
when you told me that you and your best
friend kissed each other in sixth grade
what the [ __ ] is the problem just kill
him i'm telling you right now son your
mother would be so
[ __ ] proud of you if you were here
that's not your fault i don't blame you
for that nobody knew it was loaded
now i'm a little loose but you want to
have a little fun i'll go get the keys
in your gun
i'll take you on a ride along you want
to go on a ride along yes and it's not
like that kevin hart movie [ __ ] this is
real deal
we're gonna go find somebody we're gonna
go get